ça n'a l'air de rien mais c'est banlieue
paisible sur le bord de l'autoroute 4
qui mène à orlando sont devenues un
véritable champ de bataille électorale
ce n'est donc pas une surprise si le
président américain visite la région il
martèle partout qu'il est une cible très
clair pour y arriver la femme blanche de
banlieue qui l'a aidé à remporter
l'élection
il ya quatre ans sur lemon way you lie
[Applaudissements]
c'était le premier rassemblement pro
trump pour diana mais guy mère
monoparentale de deux enfants il est
convaincu de la victoire du président
car oui si joe biden gagne selon elle ce
serait le chaos dans sa banlieue
richard guay a pour la première fois
tenu à afficher clairement son choix
politiques
elle n'est pas la seule dans le quartier
les pancartes bye jon harris fleurissent
un peu partout ce qui est plutôt nouveau
dans le comté de semenov un bastion
républicain où les femmes sont plus
nombreuses que les hommes d'ailleurs
brenda tomkins une ancienne républicaine
milite depuis quelques élections pour le
parti démocrate
elle estime que le comté pourrait bel et
bien basculer vers le bleu démocrate et
il est temps de diana maggie elle n'en
démord pas les rassemblements bondé pour
trump feront mentir les sondages
car si les démocrates gagnent c'est le
début de la fin elle possède d'ailleurs
la r15 une mitraillette et plusieurs
armes semi-automatiques sentiment d'être
menacés n'est que le fruit du climat
instauré par le président richard
le résultat dans ce comté sera
probablement représentative du résultat
final de l'état au complet donald trump
saura donc dans moins de trois semaines
s'il a bien fait de parier sur les
femmes blanches de banlieue ici frédéric
arnould radio canada monique marie en
floride